I think we got to try to give our
children the best we possibly can and I
think we're moving in that direction
here so I'm very excited
national school choice week gives us an
unprecedented opportunity to shine an
effective spotlight on the need for
enhanced educational options for parents
we have hundreds of events going on all
across the country in every state and
these are planned by a diverse
bipartisan group of people who believe
that education in our country needs to
be focused not on systems not on
bureaucrats nylon buildings not on adult
jobs but around one simple premise
educating kids so they can get a good
future and great jobs don't care you
like vouchers you like public charter
schools you like private schools you
like religious schools online learning
we don't care we like school choice I
think our goal here has got to be to
keep the momentum in the right direction
we got some really good schools have
some really good charter schools can't
have time we're seeing here let's keep
the good ones hasn't proved the ones
that are less good and let's keep moving
people tend to focus more on adult
issues than kid issues and if we focus
on children then I think it's very clear
we wouldn't be arguing about who
controls the dollars we wouldn't be
having conversations where people say
well we're taking money away from the
school system and this is about kids
particularly kids of color I feel like
school choice is the most important
civil rights issue of our time I think
it guarantees that no child is
discriminated against on the basis of
zip code you know what we should be
about is providing dollars to help kids
access a quality education if they can't
get it in one environment or they need
to get in a different environment we
need to provide the opportunity for that
to happen I think that's just a big
barrier you know there are a lot of
people that have grown up in the
traditional public school system who
think you know somehow that that system
can still work with the diversity of
need and interest that we have my
teachers are my mentors and my
supporters I know that I can look to
them for guidance and I no longer have
any fears of not succeeding at the
College of my choice I'm on the State
Board of elementary and secondary
education you know I think we have a
real opportunity here in New Orleans to
stop and say we have a real chance to do
this and increase even more sense of
possibility
around an issue that's so incredibly
vital to children achieving the bottom
line is we believe in educational choice
and competition in Louisiana
my name is Johan Johan John jr. and musk
and I go to st. Peter Claver I'm just
looking for good school to send all
through my children together cuz i don't
want him to be separated and it's kind
of hard right now because we just you
know still real rebuilding New Orleans
like this little when she's about to go
to high school huh guys like school no I
love school kind of every meeting I go
to the last four years I've had the
status quo tell me Chaz we can't do what
you want to do we need more time and we
need more money well I'm here to tell
you our kids don't have more time and
our families don't have more money
you
legendary mr. ellis marsalis
you
I'm here this weekend to kick off
national school choice week because of
all of the amazing things that are
happening in New Orleans post-katrina
particularly with the public K through
12 education system the students are
doing well the fact that parents have
the ability to send their childhood
virtually any school they want to i
think is probably one of the most
important things we've seen happen in
the education system in a very very long
time we need it for the kids we really
do you know this is our city we love it
so you know we welcome anything that's
gonna better us you know